that cloud you see is in fact a colossal
swarm of thimble jellyfish each no
bigger than your thumb nail these
jellyfish are 95% water they are in a
sense separate from and a part of the
sea at the same time
they've survived for 650 million years
and yet they have no brain no heart no
blood no gills and no complex nervous
system somehow they can taste smell and
balance themselves a fairly complex task
not every jelly is so tiny luminous moon
jellies from some angles look like huge
cathedrals of light in the sea from
another angle they look like the swaying
hoop skirts of dancing mushrooms in an
animated movie 10,000 of them hang out
together at a time and just like the
thimble jellies there isn't one brain
among them